fall guys season two is on
the way and mediatonic has given us a
first look at
what we can expect for the new season
update there are screenshots and a brand
new trailer and guess what we're gonna
break it down here in today's new video
people of the internet redshirt contour
here and if we're meeting for the first
time i'm just a dad who loves video
games and the stories they tell
we post videos twice a week here on
youtube and today we're looking at that
brand new
fall guys trailer for season two let's
go ahead and get straight
into the trailer okay so we're gonna go
straight from the beginning here guys
this is the trailer on the official
playstation youtube channel and i'm just
gonna start it from the beginning here
and we'll
roll roll it
all right let's stop it right there and
we get our first
glimpse at some of the new costumes for
season two
and right away you can see that it's
going to be a
medieval theme which i am totally down
for
as a fan of fantasy novels so let's
start right here in the bottom
left corner of the screen it looks like
we have some sort of dragon here you've
got the wings on the back
very nice touch there and then up here
it looks like kind of like a witch i
think we're gonna see more of this one
here in a second you got the hat right
there
uh and then this nice little belt and
kind of a purple
purple uh robe here it looks like over
here we've got the
knight and he's got his little helmet
here looks like this one looks very
similar just maybe an alternate color
and then here we have kind of like our
cross between geez i don't know
gandalf and maybe some sort of viking
lord
oh i see how he has it kind of tied down
here so definitely maybe more viking
than than wizard right here
all right let's keep going
okay so we're gonna stop it here and now
we get another look at some of those new
skins that we just saw here's the dragon
one
here's the which one right here also
notice that the the witch does have
glasses here now this is one of the
brand new levels and it's probably gonna
look a little bit blurry here how
with us going back and watching the
video that's already on youtube here
but i think this stage looks incredibly
interesting and i'll tell you why
it is mainly because look at this
cooperative nature
that we have going on here so one of the
things that i
loved about seesaw is the first time you
play through seesaw it's like
it's disastrous i mean still it's kind
of disastrous a lot of times anyway
but the more that players started to get
used to see-saw and understand
the more players start to understand
what it is and how it works they
know that they have to work together so
you can see here because they're not all
in different colors this is this is kind
of a race style course right here so
this is
not set up as team games yet they're
having to work together to kind of
traverse this
wall here and the dragon has kind of
surged forward and hopped on the little
block
so i don't think we're gonna keep
watching the video and see but we don't
really know
where the blocks kind of start out let's
let it roll ahead a little bit
so right there you see okay now they've
jumped across got another little wizard
kind of in the back right there with the
blue hat
and the the little yellow stars and
moons on there
in season two you'll be dressing your
full guy as a medieval so i'm gonna stop
it right there so
this is the level that we just gotta
look at so you see it's it's got
one two three four and then if you count
this area up here
five different little areas that you
have to
traverse and all of them have these
little blocks that i don't know if
they're just gonna start
scattered out if they're going to kind
of fall from the sky
who knows maybe they're going to get
launched down to us or maybe they're
just going to be there waiting
but this is going to open up for a
really interesting
and somewhat of a new dynamic
for fall guys in that this is not going
to be a team game yet
we're going to have to work together to
be able to
traverse over these walls here so it's
going to set up for some insane
insane log jams with people trying to
jump on to the platform and then get
over
the wall it's going to be great and then
if you look really closely up here at
the top
you see you have kind of these spikes
that are no doubt going to be swinging
back and forth as kind of a
a final obstacle for you to get across
here so let's go ahead and go forward
and competing across brand new rounds
all right so these are now they're kind
of just rolling through the screenshots
here
here's another look uh at a screenshot
now
what i'm unclear about i i think this
means that
is i can't tell if the water is going to
be in here
like where the purple is or if these are
two separate size here
it might be two separate sides but
regardless we've got kind of these
these saws going back and forth
again sticking with that medieval vibe
which i love both these courses i gotta
say
uh look to be quite long like this one
when i first saw it i thought oh maybe
that's a new final game but
if you look at the end it definitely
looks like it's set up to be a race
style instead so i don't know that it's
going to be for the finals i suppose
they could set it up
a little bit differently and just you
know have you cross this finish line
that could be the final game
but it's really interesting so this one
you're going to have to kind of make
your way through the saws here and then
you've got these sort of
spinning spiked logs right here actually
if you look
really closely you can kind of see a
little yellow fall guy down there on on
each of these making their way across
and then you have a little area right
here we're going to be able to rest for
a moment and then rather than
three spinning ones like we have here it
goes down to just two spinning ones
instead now this is where it gets really
interesting because now you have this
downward slope and it looks like some
slime there too
so your speed is going to be very
different uh
and you're going to have to contend with
the little saws that are going to be
swinging on both sides
but then you're still not done you're
still not done even when you make it to
the bottom of that then you're going to
have to make your way through this area
and i imagine these giant logs with the
spikes on it are kind of gonna
i mean i would guess they're gonna sort
of sort of rotate back and forth like
this
and i believe there are holes here in
this little platform
yeah you can definitely see it right
there and i think there's one right here
and right here
and then off to the sides as well so
this is going to be an area where you
can
easily get knocked off and and these
look i mean from the perspective that
we're seeing this right now
these look to be quite large so i mean
this could knock off you know
10 people at a time it looks like if you
had enough kind of
group together so then once you finally
make it through
through here then you're going to have
to traverse
up this right here now i i don't know
this doesn't look like the traditional
slime that we're used to you see it's a
little bit of a different color from the
one over here
but this looks like it is going up to me
i don't know maybe it's just kind of a
weird perspective
thing but that looks like it's going up
right there
uh yeah i mean it's definitely going up
you can see you can see right here
but what exactly is this right here is
this gonna be something that we're
having to climb this is kind of a new
mechanic
i'm not sure or maybe we're just gonna
go really slow up it's sort of like fall
mountain that that could that could be
it
and then you get right here and you've
got these three
wooden beams extending across
and what's really kind of strange
bizarre
uh worrisome i don't know about this is
that
they're showing one that is kind of
drawn up
right here so i'm wondering
is this going to be automatic like
they're just they're just going to
alternate which one is going up and
which one's going down
and you never know which one is there
going to be a pattern to it or
is there something in the level that
kind of triggers
when these go up i i don't know but you
see i mean this has a ton
of obstacles so it's probably going to
be one of the early race levels
uh or i mean who knows maybe possibly
maybe it's going to be one of the final
showdowns i i don't expect it to be a
final game but
hey we nev you never know right and so
then once you finally do make it up
there though
then you reach the finish line all right
let's go ahead and uh progress on
through the video here
epic quests from the middle oh now here
is another one so this looks like
a little bit of a different take on the
egg collecting game that we have already
so you've got all these eggs here in the
middle
yet there's also some spikes involved
now this one we know it's a team game
because of all the color themes so
you've got the two red right here you've
got a blue
here and a blue over here and then you
have a
yellow kind of off up here so this one
is definitely going to be team based
and we can't really see where exactly
they're trying to take these two so we
don't know if it's going to be
exactly like the current egg collection
or or something a little bit different
traverse giant drawbridges dodge
swinging and here's another one so this
looks like a different take on hoopsie
daisy here
so you've got the little hoops around
but you also have all of these ramps and
like another kind of drawbridge right
here
so i'm assuming that this is going to be
going up and down
maybe oh wait we see a little blue guy
down here if we look really close and oh
it looks to me like the blue guy is
trying to push it
he's it looks like he's trying to push
that down to me i don't know maybe it's
automatic but
it looks like he is definitely trying to
push that right
there so i think this is going to be
pretty similar to whoopsie daisy
obviously with just
some different traversal mechanics here
and so i think that's the same one oh
there we go we get a closer look at him
and it definitely looks like he is doing
something to either
raise or uh lower that bridge right
there
so maybe maybe somebody's on the other
side and he he's trying to raise it up
so they can't
run up there and get something i don't
know or maybe he's trying to lower it
down
show glory now this one this one they
just show
really quick let me see if we can go
back just just a couple of frames here
so this one you can see that we've got
one two three
four just giant walls to get over
and i don't know if we're going to have
have something that do we have to knock
these over
it it almost looks like like a door
crash
but these look like bricks here to me
and then i can't tell if this is meant
to be water
or if it's just a slightly different
color maybe maybe it's a
slippery right here or something so
maybe we're gonna have to use other fall
guys to climb how crazy would that be
if they brought in kind of a new
mechanic so yeah i have no idea on this
one how we're going to
to get up and climb over those walls
because i don't think let's go back is
it's not the same as the one that showed
at the very beginning
is it let's take another quick look here
it does look very similar no see yeah
that's that's different because this one
it
it has walls but they they're they these
kind of
increase as you go so see this one's
kind of a small wall that one's medium
and that one's large
then though when we get to over here
this is completely different so
they they do look very similar but this
one yeah it's
it's slightly different so i have no
idea how how we're going to traverse
over these right here
glory
okay this could be the one so maybe it
is the same as that first one
but perhaps they
i don't know perhaps it's just a
slightly different kind of
coloration of the level okay so let's
get a good look at that right there
and look at this no they are definitely
different so this one ends
with a slope going up no spikes kind of
swinging back and forth
but they do look they do look very
similar
all right there's another look at the uh
kind of new hoopsie daisy level we
talked about
ah now the new costumes fresh medieval
styles okay so now we get an even better
look at these guys let's go back a
couple frames here so we can make sure
we get a look at the first one right
here all right so there's our knight
in shining armor i like that one that
that one looks really cool
and then we have kind of our viking
warrior and then it goes right into the
wizard
this wizard's got a nice beard and he's
got he's rocking the glasses there
oh i didn't even notice the boots until
right now look at that he's got the
little boots with the star on top
love it
another color of the dragon so it's not
just the dragon we saw in the opening
oh and then kind of like this black dark
mage right here
look at that man look at that with a
skull on top
the black and then the kind of that
shiny blue belt buckle right there
with the pink shoes and the green hair i
love it
and then a female version of our viking
and then another knight right there
okay so this one we're getting a good
look right now at what
the co-op mechanics might look like on
that level where you have these blocks
that you have to stack
and work together to make it across
and here's the whoopsie daisy level
so we can see it is definitely team
based
now what do you guys think would be a
fair price
for an updated season of fall guys
knowing what we know now obviously we
don't have all the details yet
but one thing that they haven't really
talked about is what their seasonal
model is going to look like
price wise i remember back in the early
days of fortnight one of the reasons
that i kept buying the battle pass
is because i didn't have to spend real
money on it i bought that very
first battle pass and through that
battle pass i unlocked enough
v bucks that i was just able to
continuously buy the battle pass so
i don't know are they going to use kudos
are they going to use crowns
are they going to use just regular
monetary currency
instead it it'll be interesting to see
what type of model they go with
because frankly the game as as most of
you know it is free right now on
playstation plus
20 bucks on steam so if you compare it
to a lot of the other games with that
seasonal model
you know fortnite obviously went
completely free then you have something
like warzone that also goes completely
free
fall guys on the other hand charging
initially
let's see what they do from here if they
continue to charge twenty dollars if
they let you pay with kudos
instead let me know what you guys think
down in the comments below
i hope you enjoyed our breakdown here of
the season two sneak peek if you did
enjoy the video make sure you give it a
thumbs up before you go
and i appreciate you watching and i'll
talk to you again soon